[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey young man what's your name
um can
[Music]
kenneth how old are you
i'm i'm this many
oh wow would you like some candy
yeah good boy
[Music]
com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
that's called a shut up sip toca now and
what's going on we just heard you the
first voice we hear on this show i don't
i don't think we're on youtube you don't
think we're on youtube no well okay so
this is just a mug club right now so mug
club you understand the complications
here is we love you we're going to be
taking your chat but youtube's an
[ __ ]
one giant are we banned no i don't think
i don't think we're banned i think it's
a technical difficulty all right so
let's we're going to pause this and then
we are going to uh start it from the top
sorry michael we'll be right back we'll
once we get the youtube stuff uh working
and we'll reintro and all that so enjoy
the wholesome street fair again we'll be
right back
[Music]
so
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
perhaps the moon knows the secret of the
new sound
[Music]
let us begin our quest to find
a new sound
[Music]
okay let's have fun
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
my name is mr susan you must choose and
now it's time for you to do the chosen
[Music]
cabinets can i get out will it get out
crosstalk
[Music]
[Music]
hey young man what's your name
um
ken
kenneth how old are you
i'm i'm this many oh wow would you like
some candy
yeah good boy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
food
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
hmm
that's a double check-in
because uh with some technical
difficulties we're not streaming to
youtube uh just on the mug club so if
you're on youtube you missed it yeah
you're never going to get that you're
never going to get that back
it's the kind of gold that i mean i
can't even we can't even describe it
that's the funniest joke i've ever heard
in my life i just it was great well
don't spoil it well
your life yeah
uh glad to be with you it's a bit it's a
slow news day what i say that when the
north korea is firing off rockets israel
just said the covet booster isn't uh
everything it's cracked up to be new
york is in a state of disrepair but it's
still relatively uh slow and a meteor is
sadly missing us yes
no you mean comet um whatever meteor
would only cause minimal damage we're
praying for a comet right something
large planet collide i don't know what
an asteroid is all i know is they're
flat
i know what a hemorrhoid get hit with a
disc true at all
okay it's more of a firmament so oh my
gosh we're gonna be talking about a lot
here today but first let me let you know
if ever we are not here on youtube this
was not youtube's fault today full
disclosure this was uh we had technical
difficulties here with the tricaster all
this stuff but
show is monday through thursday 10 a.m
eastern you can tune in and watch us on
rumble you can tune and watch us on mug
club if we are not on youtube we will
let you know but every now and then we
get suspended uh hit the notification
bell still if you're there because
that's the best way to stay tuned
and uh i do have a question
before we move on
which state
do you guys believe is the most uh
degenerate
of all the crappy states right now
that's like which one you comment below
that's a big screw you to the youtube
gods by the way yeah is it this
yeah
and are you in one of those states our
biggest audience uh shares are in
california and new york really yeah and
uh also looking for freedom also our
audience has an uncharacteristically
high suicide rate ah that's not good at
all very high wow really unreal should
we stop broadcasting anything a part of
me you know
good work you guys keep it up
setting an example the state's it's
losing population
so you know a couple more of you you
know no look take one for the team we
need some more electoral votes oh my
gosh get yourself a plane so before we
move on we'll be talking about the uh
we'll be talking about the states we'll
be talking about wisconsin right now
ballot boxes guess what that's no longer
a thing not going to be allowed oh i'm
going to be talking about the booster
and i know look one thing too is i know
there's been a lot of defeatism out
there
so the theme here today is really
what is not what does not quitting look
like because sometimes people say oh i
never quit look you don't just continue
doing something for the rest of your
life did michael jordan quit
no of course not did wayne gretzky quit
no of course not when winston churchill
was ousted because he didn't want
socialized healthcare does that mean
that he quit no of course not but
we do need to define what it means to
not quit and i some of it's hopefully
positive for you but some of it is a
little bit uh might be a blast of cold
water to the face not everyone who uh
failed to quit everyone who continued is
successful however there is nobody who's
ever been successful there's never been
a country that's ever been successful
without the quality
of never quitting yeah so it's a
requirement but it's not a guarantee
before we get to it and we're going to
go through what that looks like just
like we did yesterday you're lying in
the sand we were talking about the
vaccination mandates we were talking
about the recent polls this is a time in
our country even though it's a slow news
day to be a lot of penis jokes
is that because i get that people feel
defeated i get that people out there
think what can we do there's a lot we
can do and there's a there's a huge
silver lining right now in this country
before we move on gerald a gerald c was
deflated how are you i am well don't
ever bring that person up again we have
an agreement never met him
zee never met never met z you have no
idea who's using but i'm glad that
you're doing well oh how are you though
uh you know
perseverance yes perseverance grit i
believe that some people uh refer to
intestinal true grit which is where jeff
bridges is the exact same character he's
done for the last 19 years and i all act
like he deserves an academy i celebrate
all of them his entire catalogue hey
jeff bridges we need to play a cowboy
you're never going to play a cowboy
hey jeff brilliant we need you to play a
country music singer we got him down
down by the river hey we need to we need
you to play a college basketball coach
hey come on blue trip
[Laughter]
we need you to play the dude where you
talk to a cowboy oh listen cowboy i
don't know who you think you are but i'm
not a cowboy with your cowboy
i was in white squall or was it my
brother i don't know uh we have you just
heard him he is here right now and he's
going to be doing uh a mission of love
fundraiser this friday in mountain oh
michigan dave landa how are you sir ahoy
i'm good man can't complain no does any
of that fundraiser you still take a fee
i take none
i give 100 back that's awesome that's
silly
uh it's because let's be clear i'm a
great person those saint judes
charlatans worked you yes they did they
worked me over good yes they did
they beat me about my phone oh dave's
coming here he has a guilt complex
better get the clippers
please dave they're like do you want
this money and they have a bald kid try
to hand it to me
this is
really not nice guys almost as bad as
when they had ricky gervais do the jerry
lewis telethon yes
our next presenter looks like charlie
brown i don't care
it was much worse to have jerry lewis do
the jerry
all right before we move on to
everything else like i said there's a
silver lining but there still is uh uh
some reason for despair uh our army
uh army of one no is uh well that's
really that's the uh canadian army
slogan
army uh our soldiers showcase their
beautiful and brave ability to fend off
foreign threats the ladies of our army
on tick tock
[Music]
we're doomed by the way go back and play
that i love the white chick in the
middle who's clearly dancing to her own
rhythm she doesn't even know the song
let's play this again this is the most
offensive part right in the middle
[Music]
right in the middle now watch when they
all do our spin she i think she goes the
wrong way
well hold on here
oh they're just
but in her defense she might have joined
the army to be in the army she might
have yeah yeah they're like we gotta go
to a tick-tock dance video and it's like
sorry are we killing people there is
that code
what they do is they send them in first
yes
they really more throw them in
ammunition yeah yeah you make sure they
get all their bullets out and then we go
in and send in the real soldiers yes
it's like hey are we okay to do
tick-tocking here in the barracks yeah
sure you guys can do that why because we
need human trenches too this is the pawn
division yes yes exactly you go first i
mean look they're not even good at
dancing
which is concerning yeah because you
know that's a sign of coordination it is
being in concert should be able to do
that as one teamwork
so i could see how it would translate
sort of like ballroom dancing some
wrestlers would take it or judo guys
would take it because it sort of
translates to footwork or boxers would
do it yeah
so i get it but they're not even good at
it which um it is palsy of the
government to think that nine women will
agree on something that is true yes
they will level their and their cycles
will align
yes
only if they take that they will attract
bears yes they will attract bears that's
what we're hoping for free bear soldiers
so if they get into a conflict with
let's say i don't know potential uh
threat yeah china and it's settled by a
dance-off we're still screwed
[Music]
i got some love
it's hard to deal chinese the goggles
[Music]
they would have them doing that but
their sisters were killed at birth yes
well listen they don't have enough
even more impressive though kevin told
us that that's high altitude training
seven seventeen hundred feet seventeen
thousand seventeen thousand feet can you
imagine
our fat pride activists at seventeen
thousand you have lizzo up there
carrying her cpap well this is the funny
thing is your iron lung your body starts
trying to kill you which is you know
lizzo at sea level yes so we're always
worried about chemical warfare and now
we're just having dance-offs yes yes
exactly that's the better way to solve
it it's really not that bad of an idea
yeah it's the bring it on way no no no
no no more need chemical don't watch
step up fall no meat no meat chemical
what you do american military no need
chemicals
dance yeah you're brave and beautiful
get fat get fat come fight
yeah they sent us tick tock just to get
us all not paying yes exactly they're
like now we're gonna learn compton team
yes
where the one white guy goes down and
all the black people are like well i
don't like it but he's got games so i
respect him yeah absolutely let's put
him in a public school let him be the
teacher
why not by the way before we go on to uh
israel who's uh they're they're wise
enough here a little bit as it relates
to covet uh yesterday this is news
ex-fbi agent vince pinkoke made new
discoveries regarding the famous
betrayer of anne frank who handed her
over to the nazis so up until recently
the betrayer in question was suspected
to be george soros until uh only
recently when it was confirmed to be
george soros
i thought it was the electric guitar
they got her yeah yeah
she played hendrix
i suspect her fiercely competitive also
journaling uh attic roommate
[Laughter]
just stomping we're up here fast yes
that's a journal there's her journal
it's not even grammatically correct look
by the way here's mine penguin
publishing house yes
look let me get to chapter 14 dip my
singer in the porridge yeah she didn't
she doesn't have a monopoly on that i
did that too
the diary of sandra frank yes the diary
of sandra frank
outlaw that stage name it was sounds of
frankenmus but i figured you know
it's a little piggyback it's a little
piggyback it is surprising how they hid
that well in an attic yeah like i figure
if a nazi went in anywhere they're like
look there's only a couple places we can
look yes exactly the fact that they
would just leave places without checking
is strange and the jews thought they had
magical powers like how did you know
it's like i was outside and i saw three
stories yes
[Laughter]
they're not stupid aryans like that's
kind of the whole thing
we saw the flashlights yes these are the
flashlights
disco ball
which was ill-advised
so uh israel uh a new study has found
that and this is not me saying this
that the fourth
coveted uh shot the booster is only
partially effective and not effective
enough for them to really consider it as
part of a national strategy against
omicron but don't take my word for it
listen to the jews moving on israel was
one of the first countries to offer four
doors of the covet 19 vaccine to people
or a second booster and now a latest
israeli study has revealed that the
fourth rose of the faisal and modern
vaccine against covert 19 is only
partially effective
it is omicron variant of the virus
and declaring the preliminary results
we're doing it anywhere interesting
vaccines are safe and have shown to
produce substantial antibodies it
further said and i quote again the
vaccine is only partially effective in
defending against the omicron variant
i am a voice the jews can trust yes
who has been leading the study said that
there has been an increase in antibodies
after administering a fourth dose but it
only offers a partial defense against
the omicron variant and here to convince
you is donald sutherland in a mask
our country of uh guinea pigs yes
exactly reporting back to us yes
actually just said that it's not
effective but uh let me inject it into
your arm yeah i love how they lead that
off with like it increases your
antibodies and it's safe and then she
paused i love the pause and she's like
yes but it doesn't offer
only partially effective also in other
news condoms do nothing yes but where's
them yes
pork holes in them they work better yes
but that's because you're all buying
trojans and you're a little ambitious
so
this is actually what the british
medical journal tweeted out just to be
clear all sources references available
at outreachcredit.com you can click the
link in the description below if you're
on youtube giving repeated booster doses
of existing covid19 vaccines in
developed countries is not a sustainable
global strategy says the who instead the
focus should shift toward producing new
vaccines that work better against
transmission of emerging variants uh and
it should be noted that uh when i said
better i mispronounced work
yes
produce new vaccines that work yeah
stopped right there you're saving tons
of letters
think about this and you know what when
we started we said how many boosters
yeah how many boosters jokingly we said
like what is it four five ha ha like
they're never gonna go oh yeah you're
doing a slippery slope logical fallacy
okay i went to college too i get that
let's go through the intellectual
fallacies it's not a slippery slope if
you're slipping down a slope
you're talking about the dance stuff
again yeah yeah well well they're at
altitude it's icy
for crime shots five shots that's the
magic number four shots five shots six
shots how many variants uh we don't know
it's just and i i get it now they've
shifted to say well it's more like a flu
shot because they're very yeah but
that's not what you said it's not you
didn't say flu shot you said vaccine can
you take any responsibility can the left
today take any responsibility just for
just for bad messaging yeah can we are
we going to change the rules now to
where if you're unvaccinated we treat
you like if you don't have a flu shot
which is like nothing
i think the only people that have to
deal with that are maybe nurses that are
in contact with patients they might have
a flu shot a lot of times can we go back
to the world being not flu shot and flu
shot i agree with the british medical
journal and the who in that we should
treat the unvaccinated exactly the same
as people who've had four boosters
that's true because the nationalities
though they said yeah just this says
like oh it's only but shouldn't be a
part of a strategy because it's only
partially effective and by partially we
mean
not um so yeah treat them the same you
know what we're done now is that
argument done can we
unite as everyone wants to say let's
find common ground really let's find
common ground yeah but by the way uh
third fourth booster can't be a part of
a national strategy because it doesn't
really work and if you don't take it
we're going to take away your kids and
put you in a quarantine camp 50 of
democrats that's what they support think
about that for a second where are you
going to find common ground with that i
think we can find common ground with
this hey certain people want to be
vaccinated certain people should get
vaccinated some people don't want to be
vaccinated
that's it conversation done we leave you
the choice that's where you find com you
can only find common ground where
freedom exists you can't find common
ground with totalitarianism
it's that simple this false illusion
where people say oh we're so divided now
no no no no we're not so divided now you
have divided yourself right from the
united states of america by supporting
mandatory experimental mrna technology
being injected into every citizen lest
they lose their rights you decided to
part from the pack exactly right our
position hasn't changed our position is
what the founders wanted for us it was
the freedom to govern ourselves and to
not be ruled by a king or a monarchy at
the time right no but none of us like we
don't want to tell you what to do
we want you to have more of your money
to spend we want to have more freedom we
want you to be able to protect yourself
and say whatever the hell you want to
say and not be banned for it on anything
you're the one making rules hey by the
way before i can already see the retort
no you want to do what i can do in my
bedroom i don't care if you have a ball
gag and um mlk junior orgy couldn't care
less if you're talking about abortion i
just have a problem when it involves
killing somebody else it's so remarkably
consistent it is i don't care what car
you drive it's gotta be weird to get
pregnant from an orgy though it's like
oh i gotta go talk to nine guys well
from what i understand is if uh they
didn't enjoy it they can't conceive
true yeah that used to be the law it was
kentucky i think
well i don't think kentucky had anything
to do no i don't think kentucky had any
rape laws they were like i mean you mean
the sex regular they were like as long
as you're at least kind of sword and not
cousins okay you can be cousins okay you
can be cousins oh it's fine the third
cousins look just don't do your sister
it's not a law it's just generally
frowned upon yes
i think once i think my opinion on is
once you have four boosters and you say
the vaccinated or harming or the
unvaccinated or harming the vaccinated
yeah uh you failed yes yes that's my
opinion i thought he wrong a booster i
kind of thought was a failure based on
their thing like hey two shots and
you're good to go now all of you that
have passes right now to be able to you
know live life and work and provide for
your family you got to get a booster
because those passes aren't good now you
got to get another booster because those
pass it but but now we've got to get
another booster because those it's a bad
printing
meant that you took medicine that
doesn't work yes please
this is a silly term too people always
talk about performance enhancing drugs
every drug that a doctor gives you
should be performance enhancing or they
should be uh disbarred from malpractice
that's what medicine is supposed to be
genuinely look i want you and again this
helps with the youtube algorithm but the
beauty is we get to have these
conversations here in the comment
section before youtube bans them since
i've gotten rid of the dislike button
comment below people out there who have
been vaccinated uh okay if now the who
the british medical journal says okay
the fourth is it's not a strategy right
for those of you who said look i'll go
along with this because i want to do
what's best and i actually appreciate
the idea of wanting to help your
community yeah what's the number how
many now we're at four that's not enough
at what point do you say all right this
this is a failed experiment is it five
is it six is it seven or and i would
wager that this is the case for the
people who've gotten
the double vaccine obviously the first
two doses and a booster there's no
number that's too much they would be
glad to take it for the rest of their
lives and create a second-class
citizenry of people who didn't get it at
all i just think that's most of these
people because otherwise it's absurd
four shots no don't work name another
situation where we would be okay with
something like this right you take your
car to a shop and it's like i think it's
this problem it's gonna take us two
weeks to fix it you get a bad guy it
wasn't this yeah uh well now we think
it's this it wasn't this and you just
keep paying every time no that's not how
this works you go in and a guy's like
hey here's your problem you have a flat
tire right we didn't fix a flat tire but
you're going to have to pay again for us
to try to yeah well the antibiotics
don't even really work i didn't say get
rid of all the crabs well even if it's
free it's this massive inconvenience
well it's not even free though it's
taxpayer dollars so they're still
getting paid yeah oh i know yeah you you
know at the moment i said for you though
even if it's out of your pocket i don't
want to get in no you're right because
you're paying through your taxes yeah
which we'll get to with california they
want to double taxes well that's that in
a second because i think a vaccine
should be a lot like food three times a
day yes three boosts three boosts if
you're fasting okay fine you can take
your three shots in a four-hour window
yeah
you know people talk about a race to the
bottom we're i mean there's
okay so uh while we're talking about the
race to the bottom as we all know the
2020 election just to be clear was the
safest most secure election ever in
history
i don't know why they're slapped it goes
in order of wonderful creations and
execution it goes adam and eve
great wall of china yeah and um the 2020
election yep that's perfect that is
absolutely it's the garden of eden of
elections don't say 9 11 of elections no
no no no
so
yesterday a wisconsin judge michael
boren ruled that absentee drop boxes are
illegal
really well yeah i think uh do you have
you have the quote here from uh judge
boren he said yeah yeah it's uh it's all
good and nice but there's no authority
to do it yeah he said that the guidance
should have gone through the state
legislature not the elections commission
so almost exactly like what happened in
pennsylvania and i know remember right
where there was nothing that happened
there could have been no foul play the
issue was in pennsylvania that
conservatives argued uh it went against
the state constitution which by the way
was not even refuted they just said well
the point is moot now in wisconsin when
they have
time to do something about it before the
next election they're saying yeah it
can't be done this way right and this
isn't the first like we have
legislatures for this reason right you
pass laws and then you say here's how
we're going to do things you don't let
courts say well we're just going to
change it and go around our constitution
right the state cons now keep in mind in
2020 more than 500 drop boxes were used
in wisconsin really is that almost like
you can't put that
you can't put that non-voter fraud back
in the bottle was it like a shoe box on
a park bench could have been is that it
was technically if you read the article
for this that's the example that was
used he said by the laws they're so
broad i could put a shoe box on a park
bench one of them was just dave sitting
on a bench with a popcorn bucket it was
people just kept dropping stuff in it
like stop like i'm eating yeah well you
got free popcorn if you voted yes
now let me just give you some examples
we're not talking about 2020 and that
the ghost of uh chavez came back and
rigged the machines unless uh the my
pillow came in to fix it
but what we can point to in 2021 all
right georgia secretary of state brad
ratzenberger confirmed an investigation
into fulton county for allegedly
violating ballot dropbox form rules let
me read it new revelations that fulton
county is unable to produce all ballot
dropbox transfer documents will be
investigated thoroughly as we have no as
we have with other counties that failed
to follow georgia rules and regulations
regarding drop boxes this cannot
continue in 2019 there was the north
carolina ninth district um election that
was held and due to abnormalities and uh
the absentee voting totals uh they had
to make some changes
they had to do a new election yes a
brand new one i was trying to soften it
to not get banned but yes well that's
that's what they had to do yes it is i
mean that's facts i know that's what
usually gets us banned and it's usually
coming from me so maybe i should shut up
i wanted to continue tradition is
important to western civilization
it was all legitimate california
presidential election the primary uh
more than 100 000 mail-in ballots were
rejected six weeks after a june 2020
election in new york two congressional
seats still hadn't been decided because
the mailings about 50 000 ohio voters
received the wrong absentee ballots in
october 2020. the point is this you
don't have to believe in some grand
conspiracy to understand the reason that
other countries laugh
at our lacks absentee voting laws yeah
countries that are far more liberal
because there are problems with it you
don't even have to get down the trail to
voter fraud there are already documented
cases to the tunes of millions of votes
that were problems just because of human
error yeah exactly and people not being
able to fill out their ballots the mail
not getting the ballots to them on time
have you ever lost anything in the mail
i know they're 100 they're on time and
they will never lose one of your
packages ever right that's the worst way
to do it we had data on that until 2020
people were like oh yeah let's just do
mail-in ballots and let's do dropboxes
because we can totally trust what
happens there for crying out loud i had
to get a ring doorbell because of uh of
porch thieves who were stealing my
amazon prime shower curtains well why
were you what do you think is going to
happen when you they they see the
ballots they were gold curtains stephen
everything they took from me they bring
back really trust me
you're one of the lucky ones i'm like
yeah go ahead take that wait till you
open the box yeah dave it's it's snakes
i thought about doing that just putting
your toys in the snakes in a box and
just being like here you go that would
be sure you just open up a cobra yeah
interesting
but the guy thwarts you because he has
an oboe
is that what they use the oboe with the
cobra can someone comment and let me
know what's the instrument they use is
it the oboe i don't know with the cobra
it sounds like why does it work
like could you use a clarinet there's
probably a guy who kept getting bit by
his cobra and was like i got an invented
instrument no it was probably a family
lineage that kept getting bitten by
cobras and they use the wrong ones like
recorder no get the drums it's not
working only making it better oh
oh the cobra don't like you
i don't know how they figured that out i
also don't know who figured out how the
first person who ate a pineapple it must
have been a lot of trial and error
you know koalas have syphilis who
figured that out really yeah probably a
guy who was like my pee burns yes that's
why they wear the wigs
some guy was trying to make it no
actually you know what that's a medical
misinformation it was a guy making an
excuse to his wife like ah it's just i
was a no i was just i was doing studying
koalas i wasn't at jiggles no i was just
handling the koalas
one of them spit in my mouth for extra
money what's that crabs that oh sloth i
was in the sloth exhibit
it took a while
oh these iguanas oh yeah they all have
herpes yeah for crying you can't stop
them from crawling up your butt you know
everywhere i was at a grizzly bear bath
house yes
so i got the hib
i didn't even know they had public
restrooms for business bears but uh you
know lik
what are you gonna do it's the
government they love salmon and aids
yeah that's what they that's what they
do they spread it
now uh by the way look just real quick
hong kong is going to kill 2 000 animals
because of fears of covet spread are you
serious that's what they're saying right
what kind of animals i have no idea but
probably the ones that we like that are
cuddly don't you love how they racistly
bring on an asian to discuss hong kong
how racist
we can't have someone talk about this
who isn't clearly asian somebody who
might know somebody who eats dog yes
preferably that's really what they just
did yeah right now let's see what
they're saying right now hold on on cnn
before we get to the hell escape that is
new york any trace of covid yeah there's
such a variety the way countries react
to this uh selena wang thanks so much
she just breaks
equivocate yes he's just like they're
such a
contrast yeah and one of them sucks can
you say which one cnn slaughtering 2 000
animals because of coveted transmission
fears yeah make them wear masks maybe
they're not even telling us the animal
though that's weird
2 000 animals who've never had covid
just like they never found the bat
it's just like a koala guy oh no no no
no no no no kovac no not lab comes from
bat
they still believe in animals
so you know that bad with kobe just like
koala with syphilis you know i don't
have to explain again already explain
so speaking of killing uh
new york uh is one of the worst states
in the union so we're going to go
through some states here specifically
new york and california
because it's very very clear you know we
used to have cities that were examples
of leftist utopias like detroit um like
chicago now we have whole states uh and
you can see if the policies worked well
new york and california would be they
would be paradise on earth so now we're
going to go to new york first which
brings us to our new recurring segment
empire state of crime
[Music]
so over the weekend a deranged man uh
pushed an asian woman in front of a time
square subway i know what you're
thinking uh before i explain it's i
think no you're thinking white
supremacist of course watch the clip
you push the woman on the tracks
yes i did why why
why
why
61 year old simon marshall was far from
quiet saturday as he was hauled out of
the midtown south precinct police say
he's the man accused of fatally shoving
a subway rider onto the tracks hours
earlier at the time square mta station a
second does the reporter really need to
say accused when the man said yeah i did
it because i'm god
i think i gave that guy a dollar yeah
well i think we all did i mean if god
was one of us
it's true just a slob just think about
it like a man who's accused i did it i
killed her oh why because i'm god and
you ever notice it's always that guy
claiming he's god like it's always
someone claiming that it's never like
kevin
at the copier
sitting where he's sitting like how'd
you have a good weekend yeah i got
hammered and by the way i'm jesus no
[ __ ] really you're jesus christ yeah
yeah weird it's always that totally cool
did you put your pants back on yeah well
you know what
i guess the son of man has to abide by
society yeah we were all naked to begin
with bro so the victim was
uh 40 year old michelle go of manhattan
so sad um well she was a senior manager
at uh a deliberate and a volunteer um
advocate for the homeless the killer was
a six as you saw 61 year old homeless
psychopath yeah now here's something
that matters because so this could
happen at any point we've talked about
cash bail we've talked about the
revolving door of criminals in new york
you've seen the rising crime rates all
references available out of credit.com
this is a specific instance where the
killer sister had begged the hospital to
keep him admitted
saying that she was afraid of what he
would do when he was released now this
crime was talked about initially and
then of course when we found out who
committed the anti-asian hate crime well
the media for a little while was dead
silent kind of like uh with waukesha
boulder fort worth the caliville
synagogue you know the media just kind
of moves on they do moves on down the
trail don't forget the the school
shooting in fort worth yeah you know no
i included that yeah well i didn't see
this
in a trump supporter you want to keep
yes aesthetic terror is the number one
problem in this country well that's what
i thought when i heard an idiot say that
when i heard new york city pushed in
front of a pushed in front of a subway i
thought maga hat you got to be
[Laughter]
is that like a throwback tea party ever
yeah
no doubt a guy in a powdered wig
covering his
koala syphilis one of the founders
dumping all the asians into the harbor
crying out loud now the media of course
they're going to force this to try and
fit their narrative that all violence in
the us's it's largely white people white
supremacy and i have articles here from
san francisco chronicle time cnn uh san
fran chronicle right studies show that
white people drive anti-asian hate also
men who claim to be god the conversation
right white supremacy is the root of all
race-related violence in the u.s time
wrote i'm tired of trying to educate
white people about anti-asian racism cnn
wrote white supremacy and hate are
haunting asian americans this is all
despite the fact that what is the number
28 i think it's 28 of crimes against
asian victims are in fact committed by
black americans oh what the highest of
any of any race interracial crime just
for context and also ironically the san
francisco chronicle would write about
that because uh 2008 san francisco
police department survey found 85
percent
of all physical assault crimes all in
the bay area consisted of a black
attacker on an asian victim what you
yeah i'm sorry steven you meant to say
white yes yeah this is all brand new
because you know when you watch mannis
the society that was made you know 30
years ago yeah i feel sorry for your
mother yeah and then they shoot him and
his wife and uh welcome to new york
that one was compton but let's say
they'll inspire you you'll step in hobo
poop
that parody has to be made
i actually wrote one
what
i have in new york we both wrote them
you should have like you wrote it
together
oh yeah i wrote one and then you wrote
one then we should combine it to make it
a superpower yeah
first i raised a hobo man then i went a
subway then i pushed the asian lady
right on the subway
what you can't say you rub subway with
subway destiny's child did it so why
can't i though
they rhymed down like that with down
like that yeah
oh what a marvelous talent oh wow give
him an award best favorite life
not for long seriously no there's
another rapper coming out i'm saying i'm
just saying more rappers are coming out
he chose the wrong door on the sidewalk
body's surrounded in chalk
why i use a chalk though why don't you
use a hobo maybe use a sharpie then i
can get gnar
i don't even know what i'm rhyming i
just say yeah and then i rhyme ha with
ha yeah ha
five million homeless pull it out saying
grope this
here's a guest appearance from kanye
oh he's masturbating on the train
which they do
i live there it's like
everybody and nobody cares you're just
like well we don't want to go to that
side of the car the man's pleasuring
himself we'll just be over here where
spider-man's asking for change
it's a hellhole
masturbating hobo right on the subway
can't do it alone gotta do it his way
this is a commercial for burger king you
have it your way how about your way
can we ever find like when's the next
time going to come out like hey uh a
mass murderer was pushed onto the subway
tracks and was like oh well you know
that's not not the right thing to do but
it kind of took out the trash that's
like in russia where the guy did you see
the story we can bring this up i wasn't
planning on talking about this but in
russia did you see no it was a pedophile
yeah a pedophile
in russia russia let him off so this
this pedophile what happened is the guy
who killed the pedophile clear
this guy killed a pedophile who was
interested i believe in his daughter
yeah and the pedophile they ruled that
it was a suicide with the pedophile
digging his own grave and stabbing
himself 38 times
that was in russia yes i have a much
better like view of russian how oh
clearly you can tell by where the cuts
of the fact that they're all in his back
yeah exactly he was he was uh he had a
great flexibility great flexibility we
all know that pedophiles when they kill
themselves dig own grave stab themselves
exclusively in back and cut off balls
these are standard pedophile suicide
cases my hands are tight he hides
himself to tree and bled out through
crocs
yes shoved his balls in his mouth
why that is sick man of course he gouge
out eyes first with soldering on why you
ask stupid questions he sends friend's
message yes he said friend a message
that uh you know that he likes children
and then of course he had nipples sawed
off and then he chopped off both hands
yes that's very difficult
it is run of mill pedophile suicide i
don't know what you want me to do about
it
do we find that throat you guys can
bring it back up i'm sure you don't need
to search mission control find that
that's the best uh judgment i've ever
heard yes absolutely absolutely i mean
russia gets something right yeah i think
the judge actually stood up and
applauded as he was leaving
the guy just takes a bow they all do a
russian dance yeah gerard butler was
like huh that's pretty good yeah i did
something similar in the movie and now i
presented the comedic stylings from
yakov smirnoff in russia pedophile
suicide you yes
thank you that does not even make sense
then again i don't know i'm drunk let's
go to branson yes
now let's check in on california again
sorry for people who live in california
and people who live in new york i was
just there nice people yes wonderful
people but the state sucks much like new
york california is also a hellhole which
brings us to
what's new in the people's republic of
california
[Music]
so we have a few uh trends to get to in
california here's one i don't know if
you know that's a new trend
it's sort of more of a throwback it's a
throwback thursday uh cargo trains being
robbed oh really yeah this is the latest
trend it because when you run out of
stuff to steal in walgreens with cargo
trains it's only 900 of merchandise per
cart ah i was about to say like is the
threshold slightly different yeah and
there are a lot of well because it's
moving through municipalities right like
per municipality
okay yeah so uh actually they ran out of
stuff to steal at walgreens and uh now
this is the trend in california don't
take my word for it it's like a scene
out of a disaster oh my god thousands of
boxes littering the union pacific train
tracks in downtown l.a you deserve this
california
these aren't props they're packages
belonging to people from all over the
country that trade was slowly backing
away
rei thieves have been raiding the cargo
containers on the trains that stop here
to unload for months leaving behind
shredded boxes and things they don't
want like home covid tests
what they don't want
is that why there's a shortage
robert ford is the one doing it like
already had it saw
there's
trains
i love it yeah you should see what they
did to the two guys who just had that
csun
come faster
yes just the one train comes up he's
like nope
can you imagine the conductor was just
like oh windows up yeah
by the way
thomas the tank engine just got raped oh
jeez he's just too nice for this
business it's shining time raping well
dreams can come true i think i can i
think oh no no no no no no
no i don't want to please stop i can't
you're hurting me
stop pulling my steamers
i can blow your whistle baby whistle
baby so uh
we actually have uh live footage though
of another robbery uh in action um i
think uh they're covering it on cnn
right now as we're here let's see
[Music]
draw the curtains please with all due
respect your majesty we're in the middle
of the desert no one can see it from the
outside
[Music]
your majesty but you just just
[Music]
now in fact
we didn't do that that wasn't our
photoshop that was an actual bollywood
film right that was released in theaters
yeah well we got choi to jump out of the
helicopter though so that was i thought
that was real is that not how they do it
that's we didn't do it by the way what
did they leave behind was that they
spent all their budget on dancers was
that poo though i believe yeah well
california more customers you swapped it
it's a temple of poop i would see that
movie all day yes i would what's your
major interestingly if you go to the
theaters they play it all day oh that's
true that's their only release yes oh
nice releasing this weekend is uh it's a
poop train again yes again no other
releases part eight yes he pretends to
be old lady arcade just when you thought
it was safe to go back on the poop train
spoiler it's not
do a real version of that where it's
just the guy in a mask of an old woman
and everybody's like i know you're not
her yes
but he's still got a suit on you know
that's called the modern lgbtq aip
movement you can't question it there you
go but i'm waiting a dress you clearly
didn't even do the hormone replacement
there oh no skunked again
yeah they have to pretend that it's her
yeah look it's just
illegal if we don't i don't know
something yeah yeah yeah something like
that don't misgender the thief he's not
wearing any pants so here's another uh
situation going on in california just in
case again you were wondering hey what
what is this what does the left do like
in australia what do they do in europe
what do they do in canada when they have
unfettered power
well you can kind of look to california
last week california parents they won a
lawsuit forcing california schools this
is a good thing but initially california
schools were
teaching aztec chants in the curriculum
now i know what you're thinking why is
there a problem with that why would the
parents want to force them to remove the
aztec chants uh that's because
california's ethnic studies model
curriculum wow that's a phrase included
prayers to the aztec gods uh including
the loch ek affirmation which applied
directly to him i don't know look i'm
not up to speed on my
aztec gods
directly to tes cat lipoca who's god uh
this this god introduced human sacrifice
ah
to mexico so they're they're they're
good with that so they were teaching
kids yeah chance to a god who uh
encouraged human sacrifice so similar to
like abortion is that the head down the
stairs
i'm not entirely sure but either way
someone using this are mine and aztec
the same am i wrong no it's it's close
though they're close enough well i'm
sorry i don't mean to be ignorant about
you know dead things yeah
i was trying to when i was in cancun i
was uh there was a guy selling shirts
you know white people it's like aztec
and mayans right and uh i said like uh i
know i don't want any mayan shirts he
said uh oh you know i have aztec i said
no i'm looking for a incas and the guy i
swear to he was sharp as attack he goes
that's peru you dumbass
[Laughter]
okay so snopes even fact-checked this
story and claimed the chant wasn't
actually to a god rather it was the
concept of self-reflection but the
lawsuit settlement actually showed the
department had dedication education
educate you know what the point is they
didn't dispute the parents claim and uh
the chant violated the california
religious freedom clause so here to
actually tell us uh about this and
encourage us uh to uh learn more about
these mayan chances oh wow uh is our
dedicated mayan correspondent
oh yeah yeah
hi
i don't think we can hear you mine
oh is this how we do the chant how let's
go yeah
okay
[Laughter]
no wonder we don't teach it in schools
it's going to be a mel gibson movie
that's all i know yeah already was
almost gibson wants to do is focus on
death like he makes good movies mm-hmm
but you know that's all they're just no
matter what it is it's something has to
die as possible yeah mel gibson yeah you
were covered in blood in braveheart i
think we can do better with the american
revolution mel you were covered in blood
with the american revolution i think we
can do better with the mayans yes
what do you have planned i want things
to die
and to be blown in the jacuzzi because i
deserve it can we do christ it looks
like he died painfully yes even jesus is
like you can tone it down a bit yeah
jeez whoa i was there you don't know
anything about it okay i've studied this
for years like it has a happy ending i
don't give a [ __ ] you asked me to come
on for creative direction i was the guy
you will see everything but the return
[Laughter]
i want to go right up to the point
before the salvation thing that's what i
want can i do the russian pedophile
thing that i want to do i want to
until the whole point of when he returns
i will be in the hot tub awaiting a
beacher yes we don't need redemption now
if screwing up education wasn't enough
california is uh also now trying to give
uh every wait what is going on on cnn
i'm sorry i just keep getting distracted
are they are they showing the russian
military
no no no no no the russians are going to
invade ukraine but don't worry it's
totally fine
they're probably not going to do like it
harmfully right they're not going to
actually it's rubber bullets
ukraine ukraine found themselves oh with
incredible number of self-suiciding
pedophiles
oh they do that yes all of them it's
weird ukraine was rife with pedophiles
who all killed themselves by shooting
themselves in back of head nine times we
will come in the graveyard where they
all bury themselves yes shallow grave
it's pedophile preference this is well
known behavior of pedophiles vladimir is
that guy being stabbed by a russian
soldier as we speak no that is pedophile
who's lost will to live i don't know no
he's screaming please stop stabbing me
it's so set it's so sad it's really
selfish yes there is a selfish act to
commit suicide pedophile stop being
selfish he's selfish he's hitting him in
the face looks like he's hanging from
three must be carved
they have evacuated the embassy in
ukraine oh no oh why because they found
out that uh one of their ambassadors
didn't get the fourth booster the
omicron variant they're looking for all
their amazon packages yes
today never came what happened we had
tests ordered we would be prepared oh no
it's not comically a huge amount
[Laughter]
oh well well look this is what happens
stupid world we're living in you know
what though does anyone actually want to
deny this when people try to say that
donald trump was buddy buddy with putin
when people tried to say that donald
trump was buddy buddy with kim jong-un
right can you at least look at the
behavior
yeah how much did putin act up how how
many invasions about that obama how
about under obamacare did anybody's
country not
did it cease to be their country anymore
under obama yeah we had that a couple of
times in fact how about under donald
trump did china do anything no did
russia do anything no no i reasoned for
that i think kim jong-un and putin had a
call with donald trump like yes listen
he might act friendly but this man is
crazy
he literally carries button with him ah
yes he carries button and he mock me he
do deke with nuclear button
he called everything tremendous and
great it's non-stop but then when i
turned my back he have a shift pineapple
up my ass so i find out he's not really
friend no thank you for wanting me well
that's what you need in a leader go over
to the country and be like just so you
know i'm insane and they're like okay
yes hey we'll wait another three years
and we'll run facebook ads yeah yes we
will wait yes we will definitely take
the white house with strzok facebook
yes exactly insane trump's thug all the
time we will roll our dice with former
vice president uh shitpen strokeface
even if you didn't like him how can you
look at the the four years he was he was
in office especially the first three
before the democrats kind of already won
yeah right and not admit that the world
was better i know i love i love how
putin was like yes biden big tough guy
look at this guy great president yeah
it's like a kid trying to convince you
when you're disciplining him like he he
clearly doesn't want to get spanked yeah
no no don't ground me that would be the
worst putin's like oh no not advice not
for former vice president joe biden this
would be the worst thing for putin oh
what will i do now oh no i swear if you
have former vice president biden i will
i will be powerless against his stroke
face is sleepy alzheimer's patient uh oh
oh no
sidekick [ __ ] who have sex with mayor
yes
what did we do in talk show host oh no
oh i hope she doesn't take office and i
win oh i hope not if they take office we
will give ukraine russia that's how it
oh no please don't do that
where's my poison umbrella i have to
take walk to the file's house
not the one that shoots poison the one
with poison on tip this is close range
poisons
syringe tip it's old umbrella trick
now uh agb he's done that yep of course
he has done it for fun now back to
california uh
let me know guys if something's
happening right now with russia that i
need to know about mission control like
if we're going into world war iii i told
lane before the show started i was like
hey make sure you keep an eye on ukraine
also amtrak you're giving out free covid
tests yes you're looking for one in
california
hold on no no no you have to go to the
government website that is set up to
find the test and it'll tell you there's
a box by a train yes you can go look and
if you need a place to log into the
government website yeah there are
complimentary laptops available at the
amtrak station yes and also every
walgreens in california they're
complimentary absolutely you can take
anything you like yes whatever you want
900 or less
that way it's not well you got to do
that you know former vice president joe
biden doesn't even know about this right
now because he's getting the early bird
special at bob evans that's true he's
calling it a day what are you talking
about
it's over
he's been up since 3am this is
terrifying you know what you guys can uh
comment below and let me know what's uh
this is happening live of course uh
updates here with russia what you think
is going to be going and i'll also smash
that like button do you think biden gets
up to do his workouts at 3am and it's
that old machine that just like yes
yeah like you can have a cigarette while
it does it for you yeah he has a he's
wearing a leotard he's like we're the
one piece of like bathing suits
palm cheese parmesan parmesan cheese
so if education we need to go back to
california here domestically uh wasn't
enough they screwed that up uh they're
now also and i'm gonna say good thing
but then we'll give you some numbers
trying to give everyone in california
free health care oh good thing
california is poised to be
if this proposal is supported the first
state
in the country to achieve universal
access to health coverage under governor
newsome's plan unveiled in his new state
budget medical coverage would be
expected to an additional 700 thousand
californians provided they meet the
income criteria for a family of four
that means making less than thirty six
thousand five hundred seventy dollars
who hired that man to do the voice given
he believes that he will increase marine
healthcare why are you talking that way
i had a stroke
yes just before we started taping just
before we started taping by ear bleeding
it feels like it's bleeding oh i smell
burnt toast i loved playing bullwinkle i
taste pennies and i'm very scared
is anybody else's chest constricting
36th uh
biocardia
i just got my fourth booster what a
silly voice
again i just want to make sure i'm not
missing that is so bad
that's why they have the sign language
lady
if this proposal is
supported the first state
uh in the country to achieve universal
access
to health coverage yeah under governor
newsome's plan on building his new state
budget medical coverage
that's every bit as bad as i remember
this guy's signer is a clown so it helps
to kind of this is california where you
have every voice actor readily available
yeah this guy shows up
that's the good news we have one of the
yeah one of the muppets
one of the pro brothers coming like nope
you don't need me all right i don't know
are you sure you're going with that guy
i mean
all right i'm the guy that does big bird
hey get out this is my gig it's union
skill
we have to tell people about free health
care i don't know they robbed a train
that was my train this is not health
care this is health coverage they say
that on purpose health care is actually
being able to see a doctor you know what
health care i'm the one who wrote the
copy don't get wise with me
i read what i write
and i write what i read
[Music]
what i've urinated
on myself
again i can't feel anything on the left
side of my body
oh no
someone pushed me i'm so cold
no no i'm hot
it's like how do we make governor
newsome look cool i don't know get mr
magoo in here
get the silliest cartoon get a cartoon
ghost yeah would it be out of line for
me to ask you can we play this again no
i know i agree
i want to make sure it's real too this
man was hired
all right where is it
hey be quicker to the drone unveiled in
his new state budget medi-cal coverage
would be extended to an additional
sounds like he's mocking him
that means making less than 36 570 maybe
that's what he's doing he's just so
tired of it he's mocking news oh my gosh
and you wonder why we have no faith in
our institutions like hey why don't
americans trust the media
i'm gonna go eat a cat
doing
voice newsome's done one good thing
a
the
there's a surplus of stray cats
[Laughter]
universal cats and i find myself in
retail for retainer for voice over jobs
more people pushed in front of a trade
next
it's never been easier to find myself a
giggle of crack [ __ ] yes
the guy that played the father on my
show is loving all the crack and the men
he can't get enough of cranking men
apparently well california is the state
for him
by the way if you loved elf as a kid and
you don't know that just google the dad
don't do it it ruins everything oh boy
[Laughter]
all right you've gotten into alpha not
what you've gotten into
hello i gotta go do a voiceover for
serious news
[Music]
all i did was eat a couple of tabbies
you found yourself blowing a guy in the
subway for a bent spurt spoon
who came up with that alien muppet i'm
not the only one that has a hand in my
ass it was jerry stahl who was a heroin
house he was heroin
like this character represents me
yes he likes stuff in him feels like
he's from outer space hey jerry i'm a
hand pumping
puppet
that was just the 80s drug problem with
all the sitcoms because they were just
like we can just add a kid right they're
like yeah it's fine yeah it's fine
totally fine yeah what about an alien
who eats cats
uh yeah good that's a bunch i gotta eat
something my
so they're they're now making free
health care for everybody in california
and that'll put the total cost of
universal health care at 400 billion a
year the estimates contrast their
current total budget for the state for
the state is only 276 billion so you're
saying this is more it's more than the
total state budget
and yeah actually well right now i think
we're seeing on cnn we're just seeing
yep receiving word that uh the estimate
has just tripled for healthcare
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now this brings me to an important point
people today who think they support
socialism and marxism or that communism
is beautiful in theory you do understand
that it's based on you effectively
working six days a week hard manual
labor for the greater good of the
community you do realize that it doesn't
work if you fancy yourself a
professional stripper who couldn't make
the cut burlesque dancer for short i i i
don't even think that's too fat to be a
stripper i got a job not even close to
being a stripper
like you missed it by a little bit and
then these people today say like well i
don't think you know fat fat pride why
are we framing us in the conversation
through health well you can't say that
you can't say that all bodies are
healthy and big and beautiful and then
demand socialized healthcare do you have
any idea what stalin would have done you
would have fed a family for a week
do you know what they do first they
shoot you because you take up too many
resources and you can't do any work
right this is a bad idea you want to
switch your market but here in the
united states of america the party that
aligns itself with socialist values
wants its citizens to be as much of a
burden a drain on the system as possible
in order to buy more votes my point is
this communism has never worked right
ever socialism has effectively never
worked and everyone the argument what do
you always hear is well it hasn't been
done correctly yeah okay so the way you
do it correctly is by ensuring that the
people who provide the least and take
the most from society are in charge of
our system do i have that about right
you think it's going to be more
effective with people of a bmi of 94 or
you could pretty much do it like china
where the government just steals all of
the capitalist money and then does
whatever they want with it yeah i mean
that's always good too and you can't
find a fat person wow nary a one i'm
just glad they're outside yeah or a dog
getting some vitamin d yeah you need it
you're very pale when you're a burlesque
dancer yes you are because it's dark in
there for a reason so in order to fund
the calcare plan which is what they're
calling it uh california would roughly
have to uh double
their tax collection what they're
doing they're already really high yeah
pretty damn high they're very very look
i see where they're going with it what i
want you to do is take your taxes and
double it yes yes so that's a tax cut so
this would mean a yearly increase in
household taxes of about twelve thousand
two hundred and fifty dollars that won't
affect anybody twelve thousand two
hundred fifty dollars and i know people
before you say well hold on a second
that's just the average it only affects
the ultra rich it would actually
increase income on anyone making over
149 000 which if you know california san
francisco these areas that would not be
considered very rich but we can say
upper middle class here's the other
thing employers there's going to be an
added tax and added payroll tax for any
employees being paid more than 49 000 a
year so this tax will be levied on every
single person making 49 000 a year or
more that's uh that's that's almost all
of them in california because you can't
survive on much less than that right you
can't survive on 149 000 here
you live also when you read the tax code
this is what i do love about it one of
our researchers kevin found this add to
all of this another 2.3 uh increase in
additional taxes for to businesses for
quote
for the quote privilege of doing
business in california
oh and by the way you need to understand
these are not taxes on profits these are
taxes on revenue yes not on your profits
no on your revenue let's say let's say
you sell a billion dollars worth of
goods but you only make 100 million
dollars because you're a terrible
businessman and that's that's a really
bad profit let's go let's go with 50
million because that's grocery store
money right there they're gonna tax you
on no one spends money on groceries
there to steal them well that's that's
true yeah well but that's a bad deal
you're still paying for groceries five
finger discounts every grocery store
four finger yeah every kroger making
1.95
in california is going to have to pay a
2.3 percent tax
and they're just
everything that you have gets stolen
you're constantly being robbed there's
no police protection
all your stuff's laying on a train track
somewhere and it's like that's the
privilege of doing business in
california we assure you your business
will be horribly unsuccessful
we are aware that you have many choices
when choosing to do california yeah and
we thank you for being coerced into
here other states don't have what we're
the
staying
offering which is pure hysteria and
crime
when you guys leave california because
we know you will if this passes oh they
will everyone i met this sucks and the
place you're going to is probably better
than california so maybe give it a while
before you start trying to change it
yeah don't try and turn texas idaho
these places florida california don't do
it please just stop just stay where you
are and be kind and die well i was told
california was eventually going to fall
off of the united states and float away
i was hoping that was a promise you know
yeah that's the last time i rely on al
gore for climate advice i think it's the
san andreas fault yep
here's something you know how you know
that california is remarkably
inconsistent this is one example like
we've said we haven't changed our
position on vaccines yeah we change our
position on taxes no we change our
position on
freedom of education no firearms no
california now keep in mind this is the
place that believes that increasing
taxes are such a deterrent that they
have astronomically increased taxes not
only in tobacco products but flavored
nicotine products because they say this
will discourage people look the high
price the high price
of these tobacco products will
discourage people from purchasing it yet
they believe the opposite applies to
income
it's not like how are you going to
discourage tobacco use we're going to
increase the taxes how are you going to
encourage businesses we're going to
increase the taxes
they also think you shouldn't be allowed
to have a gun unless it's being pointed
at a cinematographer and you're filming
it yes well that's true yes precisely
it's true though i think that kazakhstan
guy should come in and roast the
california legislature i see what you're
trying to do right now i'm not in the
mood i want it no i'm too obsessed
now here's the thing i understand what
some of you are saying yeah look but
california is an exception because
they've clearly done wonderful work with
their current tax dollars at work
residents forced to walk in the street
as a massive homeless encampment covers
the sidewalk this scene in hollywood
repeated all across the city i'm living
somewhere where i don't feel safe taking
my mom for a walk they went into the
kitchen some people defecated on the
ground right to this side is the
bathrooms they defecated in the bathroom
and smeared it all over the place
smeared it
residents say they're afraid to drive
through and most wouldn't dare walk
through it day or night i love how she's
trying to just paint she's trying to be
articulated they defecated and there was
also ejaculate
just cut the black eyes like a hills
ejaculate
i think i actually got a mask on though
that would be disgusting yeah that would
they defecated all over the walls
i would burn down the bathroom
never go in there again i'm not cleaning
that california has been so effective
that not only have their trains been
robbed they now have apps to track hobo
poop but u-haul literally ran out of
trucks trying to leave california
sorry
yes i would like to get a truck to get
the hell some people calling u-haul find
their voicemails going unanswered
there's just a u-haul-shaped dust cloud
[Laughter]
any way out
we have one left oh nope bums just stole
it yeah that's uh he cut the u-haul then
going anywhere
[Laughter]
there's six left but there's just people
having sex in it
you don't want that one look you can
rent it if you want but they're gonna
put up a fight
we've tried to get them out for weeks
they've been painting with poop for
months what a hell hole
this is what you this is
and then they're like don't worry
there's gonna be free health care it's
like you have a guy paying nine thousand
dollars to live in an apartment and then
a family of 12 living for free in front
of the building right it's insane well
they're using all those boxes they found
down by the trains it's like wow this is
perfectly good roof who's ordering tents
these days
because they're getting stolen
also like houses aren't you aren't you
you know the climate alarmists aren't
you the ones you're supposed to be
resourceful look look just have the
hobos poop in the empty boxes right
just start like you don't have to let
the poop fall wherever it lies just use
the box and then put a guarantee on the
side of the box and then we can recycle
the box by slapping an amazon label on
it putting it on my porch and catching
the porch uh the porch thieves not going
to take a poop if there's no guarantee
on the box
i got the extra time
what an awful
what an awful awful place
just a complete hellhole
this they're proud of themselves
why would you live there like i live in
a place where i don't feel safe to take
my mom for a walk yeah you don't no well
and really it's just the major cities
there like if you get out oh northern
california is beautiful yeah if you get
out out of the major cities like you can
literally just walk with seeds that you
can find anywhere on planet earth and
they will actually grow in california
yeah it is super fertile and beautiful
except you get to the cities and they
just screw everything up well it's one
of those things too where you can't just
argue like well the only reason that
texas is successful is because of
natural resources no no no california
for crying out you have every possible
natural advantage that exists and by the
way you had every possible financial
advantage that existed until the recent
decades of your policies just like
detroit as a city detroit the wealthiest
city in the country i believe the world
at one point in the 1950s and now it's
the worst there has not been a
republican mayor since 1961. you have
had your way
detroit is an exemplary student and
california is the exemplary school and
new york in leftist policies again i ask
you has any california has any of this
made your state any better yeah new york
has any of this made your state any
better let's also get away from just
you want to find common ground let's get
away from the economic theories let's
get away from the general concept of
right and wrong and taxation without
representation or basically taxation
being theft as some people let's get
away from all of that
pragmatically speaking is your state
better off
california new york detroit chicago are
your cities better off here's a here's a
good metric are more people trying to
get in than out
or is it the opposite of that well if
there are more u-haul
[Applause]
trucks they're not uh yeah i i rarely
see u-hauls going into detroit no no nor
jet's pizza's deliveries no no i used to
deliver pizza and uh after my third
robbery
well dave it was you holding yourself up
yeah but they would take the pizza too
well that was you and my money the pizza
supposedly and then leave you in ditch
for dead stab wing himself 28 times i
really just went to my friend's house
got high and ate pizza and i was like i
got robbed again
you guys owe me 83 dollars
dave that's the sixth time this week
delivering over there
the thing too while we're talking about
this i told you on the outside that we
were going to talk about this we're
going to play bad movie lines on mod
club for people who are not members you
can smash that like button if you're
watching on youtube all of it helps
because if you search this show and the
title of this show it will not show up
on youtube ah well that's how
algorithmic you can search the exact
title
and you will not find it
um
people talk about this a lot uh and
people ask us because we have a lot of
viewers in new york and in california
about uh
what do we do you know you feel like you
just want to give up and i understand
that and i don't think that at a certain
point leaving a state is is giving up
that's not giving up if you're moving
out of a state but sometimes you'll have
these people who try to be motivational
speakers on instagram you know and sell
sell ass pads or whatever the hell it is
or myfit and they'll tell you that you
know all you need to succeed is just
never give up
and i hate to deliver some some tough
news for you well that's not true
that's not all you need now it's
important it is important to not give up
but it's not all you need i want to tell
you that the the the road to success is
still littered with people who didn't
give up
that being said there is no one at the
end of that trail who got there by
giving up so i want to make this clear
not giving up sticking with something
grit discipline it's it's not a
guarantee it's not a promise but it is a
requirement it is a minimum and this is
one thing we've always talked about this
on the show look if you pick fights
if you exclusively pick fights that you
only know you will win you're a bully if
you pick fights that you exclusively
know you will lose you are a fool
all you need to pick a fight and choose
in your mind to not give up is to know
that you can win to know that you can
take some steps forward so i don't want
to give you a false motivation and say
if you just never give up you will find
yourself at uh you'll find yourself at
the rainbow of success no but if you
want to even have a semblance of hope
and rather than take this as defeatism
know that okay now you have a blueprint
not giving up is a requirement you have
no chance if you give up it's not a
guarantee it's a minimal requirement and
everyone at this point
everyone watching right now everyone
listening right now you have to flip
that switch in your brain and decide it
doesn't really matter if i win or not i
only know that i can win and not giving
up is requirement you need to fight for
your states you need to fight for your
freedoms you need to take part in your
local elections you need to understand
what's happening culturally you need to
be aware of what's going on in your
family's household you need to take an
active role and you need to accept that
you're going to have to do that every
single day
every day when you wake up your head
pops off that pillow for the rest of
your life if you have any semblance of
maintaining the country that you know
and love there is no other way and there
is no promise but at least set your mind
to the minimum we all have to do it stop
pitching get to work don't give up
youtube uh you know what uh we have uh
well let's just go straight because i
don't even know if you want to show the
trailer for bad movie lines on youtube
could get us in trouble youtube piss off